en temps normal quand il n'y a pas des
lignes où les vents qu'on appelle les
elysées soufflent d'est en ouest à la
hauteur de l'équateur dans le pacifique
pendant que l'eau chaude poussé par les
vents se massent en asie l'eau froide
remonte des profondeurs de l'océan sur
la côte opposé en amérique alors que
l'air humide génère des précipitations
en asie les vents en altitude ramène de
l'air froid et sec vers l'est
ce mouvement transfert de chaleur en
boucle n'est pas immuable
parfois il se renverse durant el niño
ses vents dans le pacifique ralentissent
la chaleur arrête de se disperser vers
l'ouest l'eau froide cesse de remonter
et la masse d'eau chaude se déplace
alors vers l'est vers l'amérique